president trump and his coronavirus task
force continuing to give news
conferences to keep millions of
americans updated on the kovid 19
pandemic
but there are some in the media who are
calling for networks to stop
airing them live watch i'm not actually
sure if you want to be honest
that we should carry that live i think
we should run
snippets i think we should do it
afterwards and get the pertinent points
to the american people because he's
never
ever going to tell you the truth
obviously above my pay grade i don't
make the call but we take them
or not but it seems crazy to me that
everyone's still taking them
if it were up to me and it's not i would
stop putting those briefings on live tv
not out of spite but because it's
misinformation
my next guest says it is good that
president trump is doing these press
conferences though he says
maybe they should not be longer than 30
minutes fox news contributor and former
white house press secretary ari
fleischer he joins me now
all right i think it's kind of strange
that um you that somebody would not want
to
cover the president because one of the
things i find is that in these press
briefings sometimes the president buries
the lead
so he has like these little news nuggets
that he sprinkles throughout
and so i feel like you have to be paying
attention the entire time
yeah this is really distressing dana the
idea that in a crisis like this
there are people who don't want the
president to be seen on tv on live tv
it's not because he's accurate or
inaccurate it's actually because his
ratings
i mean his uh job approval is going up
that's the reason if his job approval
was going down they'd be the first ones
to insist on broadcasting it live
that's what's driving them they just
cannot stand to see the president have
any type of success
but it's bad for a democracy and if you
could when people start calling on the
media to censor the president at a time
like this
it's not what we should be doing right
well and it's also you know we're
talking about china and
at least you have a president of the
united states who is
out there every day taking questions
from a lot of reporters for as many
uh minutes as they want to go and last
night just speaking on the of the
international angle
secretary pompeo was talking about this
critical need
to get transparency underway
and get accurate numbers from places
like china listen
when you hear doctors fauci and berks
talk about risk
talk about fatalities trying to think
about how to model
what they need is data they need data
from italy they need data from china
they need data from iran
we need every country to step up and
provide accurate transparent
information if we can't have that if we
have disinformation instead
there are more lives that will be at
risk not only today but in the weeks
ahead as we
battle this enormous child
i thought that was so interesting
because we are asking our health
professionals to make decision decisions
based on the data that they have and we
have to ensure that this data is
accurate
not just for the united states for the
good of the world and we have to
in some way make china accountable for
that ari
no question and i i can't for the life
me understand why the press is tougher
on president trump than they are on
president xi
but they seem to be giving china a
general pass for this that
their data is not complete data their
reporting is inaccurate reporting
the fact the united states has now
surpassed china well who believes that
but the press reports it anyway
because otherwise they would have to
challenge china
and they just don't seem interested in
that it's as if there's no upside to
that bit of accurate or honest reporting
so again there's there's many reporters
are doing their best
asking scientific questions asking
substantive questions
but there's still too much of a strain
in the media where they're fighting the
last war
which is just politically confront
anything and everything donald trump
does
and really give china a pass that's not
going to cut it for this crisis the
american people want
deeper fuller reporting
the other thing is um journalists here
in america
they really could help their fellow
journalists in china
if they were to you know shine a light
on what's happening there
absolutely and that notion of
transparency which the press should be
for
which you'd like to see in the rose
garden which you'd like to see in the
briefing room the president's doing his
part i would argue
it should be applied to china as well it
should be applied to these adversary
nations we can't give them a pass
and the media should not be the ones
yielding acquiescing
not holding their feet to the fire or
pointing out that china's numbers are
not reliable
that should be a regular part of all
their reporting on the numbers from
china
i mean we put asterisks after things in
sports
why isn't there a giant asterisk after
all the chinese statistics
i like that i'm going to make a graphic
for the giant asterisk thank you so much
ari fly sure stay safe up there